so um i don't have any uh
more news on uh goran or bam um you
already probably have a statement from
uh td
um but regardless uh
the lakers set you know the tenor the
tone
uh the force the physicality um
you know for the majority of the game
and
and they just took control and uh we
weren't able to
get it back first question here in the
room tim
on the right eric you've been through a
lot of these and you know that game one
is
it's uh it's often a feeling out game
and i mean i think
all three of the times you guys have won
it you've lost game one but
can this be a motivating point can this
be just a
a wake-up call a dose of reality like
how would you it's it's com
it's high-level competition so you have
to do things with force and
and detail um and you know it's a cliche
but every single possession
counts and um there were you know
there's too many possessions where
is either poor offense possession or a
miss uh
that led to a couple poor possessions
defensively or vice versa
and you know those stacked on top of
each other can get away from you pretty
quick
uh quickly against a a very good team
like this
we're much better than we showed tonight
uh you do have to credit the lakers and
we'll get to work
sorry for the next one malik andrews
eric could you just walk us through it
appeared so
so goron left with 604 ish left in the
in the second quarter when did he
exactly hurt himself
and it looked like he if he did on the
rondo play he stayed in for a little
after maybe to test
out what was your election we don't i
don't know
you know right now i know he's as tough
as
anybody and it's the finals um
but i don't have an update you know
where he is on his foot right now
now next question ira winterman
uh eric we have talked about this before
was bam's injury just one from today or
is it exacerbating something that
previously was in place
uh i don't have that answer right now um
and then you know we'll just we'll
reevaluate them tomorrow and see where
we are
and then to follow up just on anthony
davis is never a good matchup he's so
unique you put a big on him he goes to
the perimeter
you put a small on it he goes into the
post can you take us through your
thought process with jay crowder and
sort of the what's the what's next
approach with anthony davis yeah we have
you know 48 hours to figure out what the
next
plan of attack will be he was extremely
good
tonight and we have to be better
next question jared weiss they were able
to
kind of ping the ball in and out to get
to their corner three-point shooters
how do you balance being aggressive on
the ball without getting caught in the
back like that
yeah we're better than we showed tonight
now this is a very you know
highly uh skilled talented team
they have guys at the point of the
attack
in james and davis that are going to
break your defense down
can make plays over the top so you have
to be on a string and
uh you you can't um
start to make things up uh you have to
be extremely disciplined and
uh and stay with it um there's too many
times that
uh they got us out of uh you know our
typical uh things that we do but that
that's also a big time credit to them
tim reynolds eric kind of to that while
it was somewhat
they did sort of have you chasing it at
certain times yeah the last time i
looked they were like 21st in the bubble
and three-point shooting just how much
that just catch off guard the fact that
they could make
that many that quickly yeah you know
you don't want to leave anything to
chance uh in the finals so
we clearly have to just be a lot better
you know
more uh more resolve
more commitment more multiple efforts
more communication all of these things
more trust
we have to be much better on that end
and then
yeah offensively we we also have to
generate some better looks next question
anthony chang
okay so i know it came came late and
with the lakers already holding a big
lead but how encouraging was it to see
kendrick play the way he did
in that fourth quarter and is that
something you could take moving forward
in the series
well it's uh you're always rooting for
them
you know these this has been a tough
uh playoff you know for him and
um you know these are
you know the the human side of it you
want to get them in there you want them
to play well
and based on you know where we are
you know we could use some some scoring
punch uh
and you have to guard him and he's very
skilled
um so we'll see where we are for the
next game
all right rob anyone else on youtube
i've got one last one from tab deportes
hi coach you're coaching many nba fine
art games
and you know how hard can be
these this series what is your message
for the thing after
losing tonight i don't have my message
right now
uh but i've got a night you know to
figure it out
right now it doesn't really matter what
you say it's
you know when we get to work and get
together tomorrow
thank you all right cool thank you thank
you coach thank you coach
hey jimmy okay rob go ahead on yours
your side we'll get started with mark
medina
hey jimmy um you've obviously played
through it but how's your ankle holding
up after all this
a little bit sore i'll be okay some
treatment
um and and get ready to go again
i think um i got to be ready to go so
we'll see how it feels tomorrow but i'm
going to be fine
next question mateo mayorga hey jimmy
you've talked about how every night this
team can feature a different star but
now in the midst of uncertainty
regarding the status of your teammates
bam adebayo and goran dragach do you
feel it's incumbent upon you to take
more of a role scoring the ball
uh i mean just take what the game gives
me for the most part
i still have a lot of belief in all of
my teammates i will continually
play that way um but yeah maybe so
maybe try to score a little bit more but
i still gotta
make sure that everybody else is getting
our touches and getting the shots that
they need because
we've been playing this way all year
long and that's our formula to success
thank you rachel part of what got away
from you guys in the second quarter was
the rebounding
and obviously when they play both their
bigs how do you battle that
um you just got to be tougher
we got to put up more of a fight i don't
think that we did that
um and then it doesn't help whenever we
don't make shots
it's been that way all year long
whenever we start to miss a couple shots
we don't do what we're supposed to do on
the other end
um so you know i think we should always
think about
letting our defense for sure our
rebounding uh
start it off for us and then you know
hopefully we start to make shots
malika i i know he's not your favorite
drag brother but you're
very close with goron to watch him kind
of go down like that
to fight to stay out there to want to
come back in the game to not be able to
come back in the game
how do you support him how do you let
him lean on you right now just
let him know that i and we are here for
him we know how much he wants to win how
much he wants to go to war and battle
with this
um and obviously we love him for that
and we want him out there with this
but um you know whatever the doctor do
that's that's what he got to do
i understand that he wants to go out
there and compete and obviously we
we want him out there with us but he got
to take care of himself first
next question manny navarro hey jimmy uh
k9 went in there and played really well
uh for you guys with those 18 points
just how encouraging is that
especially for a guy who's been waiting
and hungry and dying to get in there
uh that's what he does he stayed ready
he's always working on his game
and he's he's in it to winning whenever
his number and name is called
he's ready to play he knows the schemes
it looks like he's going to be in this
rotation i sure hope so because he
he definitely showed what he can do on a
big stage tonight
thank you next question nick fridell
jimmy you guys have prided yourself all
season as being a no excuse
team what do you feel like you need to
say to the rest of the group
now knowing that you got two of your
main guys
down at least for a little bit nothing
we talk about how damn near perfect that
we have to play
and that was nowhere near there's
nothing to be said we can watch all the
film in the world
we understand we know um what we did not
do
what we talked about we're gonna do we
didn't do we didn't rebound
um we didn't make them miss any shots we
didn't get back
all of those things uh led to the
deficit
that we dug our put ourselves in
next question jared weiss jimmy sorry to
tell you this but there's a wide
reporting now that
goron has a torn plantar fascia so it's
unlikely he'd be able to return
so what do you what does the team need
to do now to rally with him unlikely to
be back
um be ready to go with or without going
we're still
expected to win we still know that we
can um
like i said earlier we want that guy out
there with it he's a big part of what
we're trying to do
but until we can't have him back we got
to go out there we got to fight even
harder
we got to try to cover up what he gives
us and make up for it
we're capable of it we have to be
capable of it um
moving forward with or without going we
better hurry up and tie it up 1-1
next question andres lopez you
jimmy they kind of referenced it in a
previous question but i also wanted to
ask you a bit about kendrick nan but not
only kendrick but also the rest of the
supporting cast
we saw solomon hill get a few minutes to
it today dj got a few minutes today
in the absence of two of the main pieces
of your starting lineup
can you speak about the readiness of the
supporting castle of the miami heat and
how they stepped up tonight
uh they did well they did great and we
appreciate them for going out there and
competing
knowing the schemes doing guys strengths
on the opposing team
but they know that they know that any
any day any quarter any any minute
coach can call on them and they're
expected to produce and know what
they're doing out there
but they're pros they've been going
about this the right way all year long
we're gonna need those guys to to really
get back in this thing
that's it jimmy thank you thank you